prouve aujourd'hui se parler
d'ordinateurs pour bien commencer la
nouvelle année va partir sur les bonnes
résolutions et sur les bons produits ça
c'est le plus important
et là on a un produit qui est vachement
bien dans des étangs de la gamme
prestige de msi alors même si je sais
pas si vous connaissez et messi c'est
une marque qui est surtout connue pour
ses ordinateurs de gaming performance
puissance en dilatant racé qui marchent
merveilleusement bien et là on n'est pas
du tout son ordinateur guinea on est sur
un ordinateur je dirais plus pour les
créateurs de contenu pour les étudiants
qui veulent des ordinateurs performants
qui vont leur permettre de faire
beaucoup de choses surtout évolutif et
aussi pour les créateurs de contenu que
ce soit un vidéaste ans monteur que ce
soit en infographiste qui veulent une
machine qui va lier le savoir-faire de
msi en termes de performances en termes
d'autonomie machine très puissante très
belle mais surtout une machine plus
passe-partout une machine silencieuse
une machine de bonne qualité je vous
montre ce produit de healthy prestige et
15 pouces vous allez voir celui là
franchement n'y envoie du bois
[Musique]
ici on parle en terme de 16 vous allez
jusqu'à 16 heures d'autonomie elle
mesure 16 mm d'épaisseur je passe il
vous en rendez compte que c'est quand
même hyper temps je trouve très légère
parce qu'elle fait un bien que six kilos
alors on n'est pas sur les 16 mai a
toujours le 1 6 l et plus légère que mon
macbook pro très compact design qui est
vraiment sympa et elle a un truc est
vraiment alors ça je vous montre ça ne
c'est un truc qui est très magique c'est
qu'en fait un ordinateur portable bien
vous devrez comme ça et elle lui s'il
voulait travailler à regarder vous
l'ouvrez tac comme ça ça c'est vachement
cool pour les présentations pour pouvoir
bosser de différentes manières c'est
vraiment hyper pratique ça c'est un peu
le tour passe passe mais ce qui est
vraiment vraiment vraiment chouette là
dedans c'est ce qu'on trouve sous le
capot en termes de performances un des
points forts de ce produit c'est
vraiment son design qui est épuré il ya
des lignes qui sont vraiment hyper hyper
sobre on est vraiment loin de l'univers
gaming qui est vraiment très très très
très très très typée haut niveau de la
ligne et du design ya vraiment un
excellent travail qui a été fait pour
venir faire ressortir les contours que
ce soit au niveau du trackpad ou au
niveau du châssis en lui même se voit
quel ordinateur on se retrouve vraiment
très très très loin de l'univers gaming
de msi en tout cas d'un point de vue
purement esthétique il est sobre
vous avez un designer guindé il est noté
sais pas si vous le voyez bien la même
avec des reflets prestige qui est
vraiment grave et ici c'est un produit
qui est extrêmement bien travaillé
extrêmement bien réussi l'idée de base
de cette bécane c'est avant tout la
polyvalence vous avez un ordinateur cas
pour être destinée beaucoup de monde ici
le maître mot c'est la polyvalence une
machine qui vous servira un photoshop
pouvoir venir fera de la créa un light
roues pour vire retoucher vos photos un
premier accroc pour tout ce qui va être
montage vous avez ce qu'ils font aux
tables de performances intel core i7 de
10e génération là vous avez 32 gigas de
ram ddr 4 pourrait monter jusqu'à 64
giga de ram autant dire que pour la
photo autant dire que pour la vidéo que
vous êtes vraiment tranquille vous avez
de quoi faire côté graphique on nvidia
gtx 1650 max qu design 4 gigas de ram
gddr5 un refroidissement cooler boost
roi avec deux ventilateurs et trois
caloducs
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous avez
un couple processeur carte graphique qui
marchent merveilleusement bien dans ce
sens pour avoir une machine polyvalente
et performante le processeur intel core
i7 de 10e génération comme un clic vous
donne 50 % de puissance en plus par
rapport à la génération précédente
tandis que votre carte graphique nvidia
gtx 16,50 1650 comme vous voulez vous
permettra d'aller plus loin en terme de
vidéo ou même carrément si vous voulez
jouer pandémie on n'est pas sur
l'ordinateur à la base de gaming mais
jusque là en arrière en termes de
performances pour faire tourner des jeux
sans aucun problème non que ce soit pour
éditer de la vidéo ou alors carrément
pour jouer vous pouvez y aller vous êtes
vraiment tranquille si vous voulez venir
faire un petit peu de bézieux kung fu
déverrouiller très très facilement vous
avez une caméra de 720 pixels à 30
images par seconde
un autre point fort c'est ordinateur
saucisson clavier steelseries avec un
rétro éclairage blanc la course est
assez courte bon retour de touche les
touches sont idéalement bien placés
il ya un certain que je pourrais trouver
un peu étrange c'est que vous avez c'est
une toute petite touche enter valider
entrez et vous avez une grosse touche
pour revenir en arrière
bon rien de bien gênant prend très très
facilement l'habitude dans les deux cas
ça fonctionne un autre point fort son
ordinateur se sont énormes trackpad il
est vraiment très très grand ce qui fait
que votre doigt navy très facilement à
droite à gauche n'est pas bonne le
relever pour venir vous positionnez vous
naviguer facilement s'écouler en plus
ici vous avez un capteur d'empreintes
digitales située juste là vous posez
votre doigt vous déverrouillez ça va
vite et pratique vous parlez talent de
la règle des seize vous pouvez aller
jusqu'à 16 heures d'autonomie alors bien
évidemment sur d'autonomie vous les
aurez pas comme ça si vous utilisez des
programmes qui sont un petit peu
gourmands les 16 heures vous ne les
aurais pas si vous tournez sur un
premier fait beaucoup de montage
beaucoup de câbles sous photoshop
les 16 heures il faut les oublier en
tout cas sur un visage un peu plus
standard vous allez pouvoir vous en
rapprocher
vous êtes sur une machine qui est
performante et si vous manquez de
batteries sachez qu'en quinze minutes de
charge vous avez deux ans d'utilisation
vous avez au plus il est là je voulais
planqué la team bloc de charge qui est
vraiment pas très très gros de 90 watts
pour recharger rapidement votre
ordinateur en termes de stockage manger
de ssd de 256 giga et au niveau des os
je tourne ici sur un windows dix
professionnels mais aussi bien être un
windows dix familles ça s'est un peu de
voir nommer un des points forts de ce pc
c'est bel et bien son écran ici on a un
écran d'une diagonale de 15,6 pouces
avec des bords qui sont quand même
vraiment franc sur le côté 500 le dessus
que vous avez le guen messi qui se
planquent juste en dessous un écran qui
vraiment de bonne qualité alors c'est
une dalle ip est ici j'ai un écran 4 cas
urgent des 3840 par 2160 pixels profil
adobe rgb il existe également en full hd
1920 par 1080 un des points essentiels
et qui est vraiment extrêmement
important quand on veut en ordinateurs
qui est destiné à la création de contenu
c'est d'avoir une colorimétrique est
vraiment extrêmement bien maîtrisé très
juste ici jeanne écran qui est
extrêmement
bien calibré avec la technologie
truecolor et un delta e qui est
inférieur à 2 pour que ce soit pour
l'édition photo ou de la vidéo
là dessus vous êtes vraiment rôle clé au
niveau de l'odeur vous avez deux
haut-parleurs de 2 watts sont planqués
juste ici de par coeur de la machine
c'est pourtant cette machine que vous
allez avoir le plus de performances au
niveau lieu par contre ce que je vous
conseille ci voulait vraiment venir à
optimiser l'expérience audio ou utiliser
la prise jack qui est planqué juste là
là vous allez venir maximiser
l'expérience vous mettez un petit casque
que ce soit pour monter des vidéos pour
regarder des films des séries tout ce
que vous voulez broches un petit
casse-tête tout de suite vous allez
monter en qualité
un point qui est essentielle pour les
ordinateurs dédiés aux créateurs c'est
toute la partie connectique ici c'est
vraiment bien parce que vous avez deux
ports usb c'est thunderbolt roi qui vont
également vous savez pour choisir votre
ordinateur avec la qualcomm tchatche 3.0
et grâce au thunderbolt trois espoirs
qu'à brancher des disques durs externes
pour votre montage c'est vraiment bien
un port hdmi pour brancher un lecteur
externe si vous le souhaitez je voudrais
tout à l'heure une prise jack qui vous
servira aussi bien sortie casque une
entrée micro tandis qu'ici vous avez
deux ports usb et un lecteur de cartes
microsd pour tous les créateurs pour
venir décharger vos cartes microsd que
ce soit pour de la vidéo que ce soit
pour des photos ça s'est vraiment bien
c'est devenu extrêmement rare il ya un
autre point qui est vraiment bien c'est
ce qu'on veut dire trouver ici en bas de
votre écran
c'est toute la partie dédiée aux
créateurs c'est le créateur center et
vous permet de lire complètement
optimiser votre machine par rapport à
vos différentes applications j'ai ici
notamment quatre applications de
souvenirs soient activés soit désactivée
enfin qu'elle soit complètement optimisé
pour profiter des meilleures
performances de la machine mais issus de
venir régler toutes mes applications
jeux peut aussi venir monitoring
l'ordinateur pour savoir exactement ce
qu'il en est quelle est la partie du
processeur qui utilisaient la partie la
carte graphique à partie de la mémoire
la partie du disque si besoin je peux
libérer la mémoire je peux nettoyer mon
disque pas mal d'informations concernant
le we feel ethernet la gestion de la
batterie
la vitesse de rotation de mes deux
ventilateurs la disponibilité mon ssd
je veux vraiment revenir ensuite créer
des scénarios en fonction de ce que je
veux sur ma machine par exemple je
voudrais un scénario pour aaron plus de
performances pour avoir une vraie bonne
balance entre le meilleur des
performances et d'un côté le meilleur de
l'autonomie ou alors carrément aller
plus loin en termes d'autonomie de
baisser luminosité de l'écran et là j'ai
vraiment venir jouer sur l'économie de
la batterie je peux également vire
monitorer la santé ma batterie j'ai donc
tout ce qu'il me faut d'un point de vue
purement logicielle là dessus pour venir
optimiser ma machine comme je le
souhaite en fonction d'eux
mais besoin ces choses une session de
travail et qu'ils avaient besoin du
maximum de performance
et bien je le règle directement créateur
center je suis par contre dans une
partie un peu plus bureautique et j'ai
pas forcément besoin du maximum des
performances a bien fait plutôt dans une
partie où je vais mettre en avant
l'autonomie
on est donc sur une machine extrêmement
polyvalent comme je vous le disais qui
est destiné aux personnes qui veulent
faire de la création contenu des
personnes comme moi qui vont faire du
montage qui vont éditer des photos mais
aussi bien un étudiant qui veut une
machine performante qui veut une machine
exigeant d'autant plus qu'on pouvait
venir à paramétrer comme vous le
souhaitez il existe plusieurs
configurations je lui ai dit l'écran
full hd l'écran en 4k vous pouvez
choisir la rame que vous voulez mettre
dedans il ya pas mal de possibilités si
vous intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas
dans la description il invite à les
jeter un petit coup d'oeil et il ya un
autre point qui m'a vachement surpris
sur cette machine c'est qu'elle est
extrêmement silencieuse regarder si je
mets ça gêne micro qui a regardé le jeu
mais là je sais pas ce qu'ils attendent
et on n'entend quasiment rien elle est
vraiment très très silencieuse et ça
pour moi c'est aussi un des points
extrêmement important parce que lorsque
vous allez utiliser l'ordinateur gaming
et vous allez faire du montage dessus
vous allez pouvoir effectivement avoir
déjà beaucoup performance mais par
contre derrière ça va bien ventilé
ventilé force normale celle l'adn de
cette machine ce qu'on veut c'est
qu'elle sans franchise extrêmement
rapidement pendant le maximum de
performance alors ici vous êtes toujours
avoir beaucoup de performances
vous n'allez pas voir ce grand
ventilateur qu'à venir ronronner donc ça
s'est vraiment bien lorsque voulait
venir travailler travailler dans un
environnement un petit peu silencieux
pourquoi pas un environnement maîtrisé
et bien avec cette machine là pouvait le
faire sans aucun problème
il ya un truc dont je me lasse
absolument pas cet écran 10 mai comme ça
là ça s'est quand même hyper
impressionnant
alors on va pas tous les jours
l'utiliser comme ça vous ne casse pas
sûr assez d'accord avec vous mais c'est
vrai que si vous le souhaitez vous
faites une presse vous poser sur une
table et vous êtes nombreux cas même des
gens de l'autre côté qui veulent
regarder des choses ou des créations et
bien vous pouvez le faire
c'est vraiment extrêmement flexible donc
même si on n'a pas toujours l'utiliser
et dire on va pas forcément utiliser son
pc comme ça et bien vous pouvez le faire
et en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
dans certains cas de figure vous
pourriez en avoir besoin et lapointe
quoique ce prestige 15 pouces et bien
vous pouvez le faire bon allez donc sur
un ordinateur nomade ta forme ans qui
vous permettra de travailler partout
comme vous souhaitez vous permettra
d'être complètement créatif nomade où
vous le souhaitez
quand vous le souhaitez pour faire ce
que vous voulez personnellement je me
mets à cette machine je trouve
intéressant la trouve polyvalente
j'aime bien aimé si je trouve que la
marque est cool mais surtout ils ont
vraiment fait un très beau travail au
niveau du design avec tout ce petit
concours bleuse petit bandeau bleu
machine qui est vraiment très légère
performante vous pouvez emmener partout
avec vous à vous de dire en bas ce que
vous en pensez en commande
vous la trouvez cette machine d'un récit
la prestige 15 pouces moi je la trouve
bien et pour bien démarrer l'année pour
avoir un ordinateur qui est compact
performant qui allie vraiment un produit
esthétique et puis je vous dis parfois
moins endurants vous êtes tranquille là
dessus je vous invite à aller voir les
liens en bas dans la description de dire
ce que vous en pensez mais qui bien
évidemment vous abonner pasqua continue
à parler tech
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire on aura
beaucoup de choses à dire dans les temps
à venir plein de belles surprises aux
gabonais vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait
sur ce je vous embrasse donne rendez
vous dès demain pour étudier par les tec
à demain ciao